الحرب على اوكرانيا
واخطارها كانت حاضره في بالي كذلك وفي
انقره ايضا او بالاحرى حظر استخدام النووي
الذي كان محورا اساسيا في لقاء
الاستخبارات الامريكيه الروسيه اللقاء جمع
مدير وكاله الاستخبارات المركزيه
الامريكيه سي اي اي والامبيرز بنظره مدير
اداره الاستخبارات الروسيه الخارجيه سردين
في تركيا امس مدير سي اي اي نقل رساله الى
نظيره الروسي تتعلق بالتحذير من عواقب
استخدام اسلحه نوويه في اوكرانيا ومخاطر
تصعيد على الاستقرار الاستراتيجي العالمي
وفق ما افادت به صحيفه وسطينال الصحيفه
نقلت عنها متحدث باسم مجلس الامن القومي
في البيت الابيض ان برنس حضر نارشين بشان
عواقب استخدام روسيا للاسلحه النوويه في
اوكرانيا وذلك في اطار جهود الاداره
الامريكيه للحد من خط الصعيد الحرب
لكن اللقاء لم يكن محاوله للتفاوض مع
موسكو حول انهاء الحرب بل ان المسؤولين
الامريكيين اصروا على انهم لن يجروا
محادثات سلام دون مشاركه الحكومه
الاوكرانيه
بحسب صحيفه نيويورك الخلاف برز حول من طلب
الاجتماع وكاله الانباء التركيه وكاله
انباء الاناضول نقلت عن مسؤولين في
الاستخبارات قولهم ان برنس كين التقيا في
انقره بدعوه من وكاله الاستخبارات الوطنيه
التركيه بينما اكد المتحدث باسم الكرام
لندن لوكاله الانباء الروسيه بس ان
محادثات بين مسؤولين روسيا امريكيين جاءت
بمبادره من الجانب الامريكي رافضا الكشف
عن المحتوىها
[موسيقى]
الفن